en france à présent l'actualité
politique dès ce soir le temps de parole
d'eric zemmour est officiellement des
comptes et le chroniqueur n'est pourtant
pas encore officiellement candidat à la
prochaine présidentielle mais pour le
csa éditorialistes doit être regardée
comme un acteur du débat politique
national pour ses prises de position on
retrouve notre reporter monaco dès lors
devant le centre bonsoir mona amoud et
laure envers et contre tout haut ses
news 1 décide de garder finalement eric
zemmour à l'antenne malgré la demande du
csa de décompter son temps de parole
alors même si rien n'est officiel eric
zemmour laisse planer le doute quant à
une élection quant à une candidature
pour l'élection présidentielle pourtant
ce n'est qu'une rumeur pour le moment
rien n'est confirmé mais le csa insiste
estime que zemmour est un acteur
politique pour prendre sa décision le
gardien de l'audiovisuel s'est appuyé
sur plusieurs points notamment les
intentions de vote dans les sondages ou
encore ses soutiens qui ont affiché
plusieurs les affiches dans toutes les
rues de la ville par ailleurs le
principe du décompte ne se limite pas
seulement à des candidats déclarés à des
élus ou a même des membres de partis
politiques mais à toute personne étant
identifié comme étant ayant un rôle
actif dans le rôle dans le débat
politique selon la charte du csa est
presque comme un candidat eric zemmour a
déclaré être ouvert à rencontrer marie
le pen ou même avoir un débat avec eric
zemmour qui sont tous les deux candidats
à l'élection présidentielle ce qui sème
encore plus vous l'imaginez le doute or
l'entourage d'eric zemmour est
catégorique et balaie cette hypothèse de
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
celui qui a été condamné en 2011 pour
provocation à la haine raciale a répondu
sur twitter hausse concernant à la
décision ou la demande plutôt du csa je
cite je ne me tairais pas selon lui sa
profession de journaliste protège sa
liberté d'expression en toutes
circonstances en tout cas à la demande
du csa et bien elle divise la classe
politique notamment à droite louis
alliot marie du rassemblement national a
estimé que le csa n'a pas à s'immiscer
dans ce genre d'affaires il appelle même
eric zemmour à soutenir marine le pen à
partir du 17 septembre eric zemmour
entamera une tournée dans toute la
france pour la promotion de son nouveau
livre de quoi continuer à cultiver une
certaine ambiguïté et de quoi également
entretenir le mystère sur la suite des
événements merci mona amoud et l'or